russian state television have issued a
brazen warning that moscow could wipe
out britain with a nuclear tsunami in
retaliation for supporting ukraine
declaring there would be no survivors
in britain they seem to be rambling why
did they threaten vast russia with
nuclear weapons while they are only a
small island why do they play games
another option is to plunge britain into
the depths of the sea using russian
underwater robotic drone poseidon the
explosion of his torpedo close to
britain's shores will raise a giant wave
a tsunami up to 500 meters this tidal
wave is also a carrier of extremely high
doses of radiation surging over britain
it will turn what is left of them into
radioactive desert
well retire four-star general a former
vice chief of staff of the u.s army
general jack keane joins me as does
tobias hell with conservative mp and
former defense minister welcome to both
of you a general king first of all great
honor to have you on the show thank you
very much for for joining uh here's
morgan censored
when you hear that kind of rhetoric
from the russians and we're hearing more
and more of this now
it is pretty sobering listening isn't it
it's frankly quite terrifying to many
people uh when i interviewed president
trump earlier this week he felt that
america in particular should be using
more bellicose rhetoric back reminding
them the russians that america
has just as many nukes as they do what
is your view
well the fact is uh we have a very
effective strategic terrance about the
kind of
warfare that's being threatened here
which is
global nuclear warfare and that that
kind of language is absolutely
horrendous and certainly outrageous to
do that i don't think we have to walk up
the nuclear escalation with them but we
remind them
that there is a significant strategic
deterrence here among the united states
britain and france
and certainly the destruction of their
entire country and population is what
they're putting at risk here
i think they clearly understand that i
think this is mostly trying to rattle
your population as well as mine and also
impact our our leaders
i think what's really troubling to them
is the unanimity that the eu and nato
has
really defined here not just in in
getting better sanctions and improved
sanctions but most significantly
is the arms and ammunition that we're
providing to the ukrainians and
certainly
the backdrop here appears is the fact
that the russians have largely been
failing and even in this much smaller
offensive that they're conducting right
now
they haven't made much gains and
last 24 36 hours they haven't been doing
much
much of anything so
yes
uh there is saber rattling going on here
uh for sure now the issue with a
tactical nuclear weapon i think that
gives us all a little bit more concern
that something like that could be used
i really believe the biden
administration could be much stronger
about what our response should be here
both publicly and privately and i will
say this i do think that some of this
rattling is going on particularly as it
concerns the biden administration
appears because
the binding administration set the tone
here very early on march 21
70 000 troops show up on the ukraine
border 60 days into the biden
administration's reign
right after the inauguration it's no
accident i'm absolutely convinced
uh putin is doing that to test this
administration which he believed would
be weak
and there's an opportunity okay the
trump administration had a scheduled
deployment of arms and munitions in
march of that year planned
by administration did not execute it and
publicly stated the reason yeah they did
not want to provoke putin yeah i mean
tomorrow
let me bring in tobias elwood uh general
kennedy for me
tobias i mean i felt that one of the
things that may have empowered vladimir
putin to go into ukraine and president
trump said the same thing was the very
uh
candid if not catastrophic withdrawal of
forces from afghanistan that that looked
like it was america in a form of
surrender what did you what did you
think of that what do you think of where
we are with this war and actually what
does defeat look like now for putin
well these are all great questions
firstly good to see uh general keane uh
plea pleased to share a platform with
him but yes uh i think putin has seen
but over 30 years in fact the west has
become quite timid and our humiliation
in departing from afghanistan i think
was the ice another cake that was the
moment that he intended to strike and we
need to wake up that we are actually
witnessing a turning point in our
history this isn't just about ukraine
this is much much bigger this is about
putin taking advantage of complacency
over 30 years as we've withdrawn back on
our military capabilities
uh putin is very much now alignment with
uh president xi with china and russia
forming an access and leveraging our
timidity what we're seeing at the moment
though is an invisible invasion as
general keane just implied
in contrast incredible uh resilience and
heroism from the ukrainian forces
themselves but we haven't leveraged that
you know russia's
ineptitude caught the west off guard
remember the u.s even offered to uh
zaninski a helicopter fight out that's
how they thought uh how competent they
thought russian forces would be but here
we are ukraine doing an incredible job
russia having to back away from kiev
move around to donbass that is the
moment when they're regrouping rearming
they're starting to redeploy that's when
you launch a counter-attack but where is
the west where is nato to leverage that
the big question i pose to the west
indeed to britain and united states is
what is our objective what are we trying
to achieve in ukraine is it to support
ukrainians to push russia completely out
of mainland ukraine or are we content
with some form of stalemate occurring
over don bass we need to clarify exactly
what let me know
okay i mean look these are good
questions let me ask general keane those
questions
what do you think the west's objective
is right now and let me ask you also
general kim
what is defeat for putin and what is
victory now do we think
well first of all
i think we're very ambiguous about what
our intent there is we started out by
just arming the ukrainians certainly
to likely
uh deal with an insurgency because they
most people felt the regime was going to
be collapsed and then certainly the
ukrainians responded very positively
russians responded very incompetently
and and huge opportunity arose it took
the biden administration far too long
to make that transition
and get them the weapons they needed and
finally we're there we are clearly doing
that
i think the meeting that was held in
ramstein where 40 nations showed up 14
of them not european
uh with secretary of defense alston and
chairman of joint chiefs the united
states miley
that is significant and what we have to
do is continue that
in terms of the objective the objective
was never clear from the beginning but
now has come come much more into focus
the secretary of state the secretary of
defense the chairman the joint chiefs
others in the administration even
the speaker of the house nancy pelosi is
talking about victory here defeating the
russian military inside of ukraine which
is i believe is should be our objective
it should have been our objective and
unequivocally clearly stated from the
beginning and certainly when you when
you have ambiguity like that it actually
leverages our our enemy
russia to be sure because they're not
certain about
what what we're driving towards and
that's why i think they've been
surprised by the level of effort
recently i i think
there still is opportunity here for that
objective to be achieved and we've got
to double down and continue to robust
support that we're providing the
ukrainians plus the the moral support
that they need as well john mccain great
to talk to you tomorrow thank you very
much too really appreciate it